Chris Christopher is with us in
California huh Christopher how are you
better than I deserve sir how are you
better than I deserve sir how can I help
all right well I'm 22 years old and I
have two siblings in high school right
now and I'm just wondering what the best
way to help them financially would be
without like giving them get handouts
why do they need help financially well
we can't pick our parents and
unfortunately our parents aren't very
smart financially so I know they don't
have anything saved we were there the
college fund or anything like that so I
I might be in a spot where I'm able to
help them now okay so how much money do
you have well I have 14,000 in savings I
make around $40,000 a year but since I'm
in California that's basically ten
thousand years yeah so what is it you
can do and are thinking of doing to help
them
well I have some ideas and I was hoping
you could help me out structure those
maybe helping them invest into a car so
they can you know get a decent job and
start working for themselves I've also
thought about matching like if they save
$500 I will match that and put another
500 into savings okay you you have a
wonderful heart you don't have much
money
yeah and that yeah $14,000 and you make
40,000 adjusted for California's 10,000
I you know what you said right so you're
it's not like you called me up and I
have two million dollars and I make 200
grand a year and I want to help my kids
my kid brother in high school okay
you're not mathematically you're your
pocketbook doesn't match your heart and
you have a wonderful heart you have a
wonderful heart I appreciate you so my
point I guess is I don't want you to
damage your cell
in the name of generosity that goes
beyond and makes you financially
unhealthy because you might you might be
throwing good money after bad meaning
you might not be able to affect this
situation so my suggestion would be for
you how can you help your siblings 90
percent coaching and cheerleading 10
percent money meaning something like you
said I'll match if you save up $1,000
I'll put $1,000 with it for you to buy
your car a little two thousand dollar
car and then you but you got to go get a
job and you got a bank a bunch of that
for college and you got to start working
out a college plan and I'm gonna work
the college plan with you where you go
to college debt-free cuz mom and dad
aren't gonna pay for it and your
coaching and guiding and you're using
the little bit of money that you put
into it as leverage to cause them to
match and as leverage to keep your right
to be very forceful in your influence on
their money habits as your caster as
their loving coach yeah I want to buy
permission to be up in your grill
because I love you and I'm gonna help
you that's kind of them that's kind of
the message the underlying message so
how old are they again my little brother
he's about to be a junior in high school
crazy as it sounds he's about 16 and
then my little sister she's a freshman
she's a virgin
okay let's start it and it sounds
something like this I'm going to give
you two copies of debt-free degree by
Anthony O'Neill number one bestseller on
how to go to college without that okay
you're going to give them to brother and
you're going to give them to sister and
you're gonna say and there's a and
there's a fifty dollar bill the other
side of these books when you give me a
one page book report that shows me you
really read it okay that kind of stuff
okay so now we got the whole debt-free
degreed conversation started you put a
little money in their life you put some
coaching in love and cheerleading in
their life and now that and now that now
the tussle begins okay and that's that's
and then you walk for the next five
years with them through jobs and saving
and investing and school selection and
Community College is largely if not
completely free in most of California so
they're going to do their first two
years in Cali Community College cuz they
don't mean money during that time
they're working 50 60 hours a week while
they're in school shut up don't whine
work pile up money get ready go in state
school out of state school don't go
expensive famous school you can't afford
it you are broke people and this is you
coaching them and loving them because
your mom and dad don't know how and
you're choosing to step into that role
and reparent them on this subject and
then they're gonna look back when
they're 35 and go my Big Brother's saved
my life and that that's what you want
here but you're not going to have enough
money to write checks to save their life
but you can give them information and
some money to cause it to happen which
is actually better by the way if you
just gave them a million dollars they're
gonna go screw it up because they don't
know beans so let's teach them beans